we take all this analysis and we encode
it in the computer tools that we build
for our artists to use
so when the artists are working with
this material they just give us
those digitized points or the equivalent
of this
four-point polygon and a curve appears
and they don't really understand
how it happens um they gain some
intuition for how the curve is related
to the polygon but all that eigen
analysis and magic numbers that's all
buried inside the software
so we try to give the artists artist
friendly tools so that they can
not have to worry about you know all the
math and the numerical analysis under
the hood
so when we've done our job well the
artists you know really don't know a lot
about
the the math and physics underneath
they're they're using the tools at a
creative storytelling level the images
that you see in the theater
result from doing a simulation of how
light bounces around in our virtual
environments
and the way light bounces around in our
virtual environments
is very physically inspired so we look
to physics for the equations that govern
how light is transported and then we
write
computer tools that determine
how light is going to bounce around
ultimately to the virtual camera and
what that virtual camera sees is what
you see in the theater
another example is
how clothing and hair moves on our
characters our animators don't want to
create all that motion of the clothing
themselves they want to create the
motion for the characters because that's
where the acting comes from and then we
have to write computer simulation
that again is based on things like
differential calculus for instance that
describe how the cloth is going to move
in response to the body motion we do
water simulation we do smoke simulation
we do flesh simulation
and again all that is governed by
physics equations and numerical analysis
computer geometry is there an end game
for you guys are you guys always going
to be in a job well it's hard to see the
end game
we know a lot more than we did 20 years
ago when i started here but there are
still some big mysteries out there
one of the biggest ones is
these you know flush simulations and
cloth simulations we do
are really slow and so our animators
don't see
the result of those simulations until
much later we'd like to get to the point
where the animators are seeing the full
performance including the cloth and the
flash in real time and where
many orders of magnitude and
computational speed away from that right
now so that's we're putting a lot of
energy into that problem is there a holy
grail in animation or is there a
well-known biggest problem in animation
world where like you know
whoever cracks this one is going to make
a big leap forward in that side of
things well for a long time in computer
graphics there was the holy grail of
creating what was called a
photorealistic image that is an image
that's indistinguishable from a
photograph and we reached photorealism
oh
you know five eight years ago something
like that there's another holy grail for
many in the computer graphics industry
which is to
create a photorealistic human
and we're just now approaching the
ability to
create
digital actors that are
indistinguishable from real actors
that's not something that pixar is so
interested in uh we we like telling
stories in a very stylized way um you
know kind of
glorified cartoons in a sense but lots
of others in the industry like in visual
effects houses like industrial light and
magic
photo realism is a very important
milestone for them you know for us
physics is kind of a starting point and
physics is nice because a lot of the
audience's intuition about how things
move is you know largely driven by
physics
but our
directors
you know really want to
you know exaggerate
oftentimes
and stylized as we talked about earlier
and
the the frontier of stylized looks is
vast photo realism is just one little
tiny point so that's really exciting for
us there's lots of things you can't talk
about but you do publish papers what do
you publish papers about what's your
kind of threshold and reason for
publishing papers where's the thinking
there we have taken the philosophy that
we'll publish anything that we are proud
of and is feel and feel as publishable
and there's a few reasons for that one
is
that
um
exposing ourselves to the discipline of
publication and peer review makes our
work better because other people are
reading it and carefully critiquing it
another reason is
that uh it's a good recruiting tool um
scientists know that they can come here
and uh you know continue to participate
in the academic world they're not gonna
disappear
from the research world if if they join
us they're really nice looking academic
papers by the way yeah i guess you've
got a bit of help but quite a few people
at pixar you know co-author papers so
you'll see you know dozens and dozens of
authors on our website one was a new
hair simulation system for meredith's
hair and brave
we've also been doing a lot of work to
increase
the the warmth of the lighting and
effects that you see in our films and
that's called global illumination and
you'll see a number of papers
that folks here at pixar have written on
global elimination there have been a few
new
kinds of geometry and geometric modeling
papers that we've written recently so
it's
basically covers every discipline that
we work on here at pixar
what's it like for you watching an
animated film a pixar film even like
when you go along to one do you do you
see them for what they are or is it like
the matrix and you're just seeing a
series of numbers and equations well
films that i've worked closely on i it's
hard to watch and not see all the flaws
and
so i've what i've lately started doing
is i don't want to see anything about
the imagery in a film say nine months
away from its release and that way i can
go to the theater and enjoy it with
fresh eyes just like the rest of the
theater goers and then i just enjoy it
like anybody else what about when you
watch other animated films from that
you've had no involvement in do you
unpick things in your head and think
about the math behind it or is it not
like that it goes in fits and starts
there are some periods where i'm just
caught up in their story and there are
some periods where i go oh wow i wonder
how they did that
and i try not to do that but it's it's
really hard
so the camera really never moves all
we're doing is applying a transformation
that appears to move everything relative
to the camera there are some magic
numbers involved so let's get a sense of
what those numbers are one pair of magic
numbers are one one here those are the
weights that i used in this averaging
step when i moved things to midpoints